this is a production of cornell
university
and i can't think of a better way to
start a brassica session than with a
conversation about maggots of all things
and actually i'm first on the program to
give this presentation
to address the issue that laura's ban
is banned
and what are we gonna do to control
cabbage maggot now
so even though i was volunteered to give
this presentation i absolutely want to
acknowledge my colleagues and my peers
that are involved with this project and
they are participating in this session
so we'll be available to answer
questions
um as well so they're dr farooq zahman
he is with cornell cooperative extension
in suffolk county on long island and
brian nalt with cornell entomology at
agritech in geneva
so hopefully you all have heard that
laura's ban and its active ingredient
and other generics with this active
ingredient are banned in new york state
they are no longer allowed to be used
for feed and food uses and the last day
that it was legal to leak to use lures
ban was july 31st on in 2021 so last
july
um new york is not alone in this
recently the epa has revoked tolerances
for clerpyrophos
and it they it may no longer be used for
food or feed crop that will be sold in
the united states
that comes into the effect february 28th
2022 so that is next monday so no more
clarifier frost for food uses in the
united states or at least for crops that
are sold in the united states
so what does that leave us well this is
a list of the insecticides that are
labeled in new york on brassicas for
control of cabbage maggot they include
diazinon and various formulations of
this this is an organophosphate
which is in the same class as laura's
fan and chlorpyrifos was
radiant which is a class 5 it is labeled
as a directed spray at 100 gallons per
acre capture lfr in various generics are
pyrethroids
um that is labeled as an infero
application
corrigen and verimark are diamines group
28 labeled as trans what twist by water
drenches infero directed sprays at the
base vera mark is the only one that's
labeled as a tray drench
and vera mark are not available on long
island if there's anybody participating
from long island corrigen and radiant
are labeled for suppression only
and the reason i have capture lfr shaded
here is because um
cornell research on long island looking
at this active ingredient or the this
material as an iaf has not been
effective
so we are not recommending that for
cabbage maggot at this time
so i'm going to present to you today's
results from several research trials
um and i just want to acknowledge that
funding was from new york the new york
farm viability institute north east air
the new york cabbage research and
development program um i'd like to
acknowledge root brothers for hosting
the trial that brian and i conducted
this summer and dan gilring he's an
entomologist on long island who wins the
award for cabbage maggot longevity he's
worked with this past longer than any of
us and then a whole slew of technicians
for helping with the trial evaluations
this is my team emma and sarah and so
with cat we want to control cabbage
maggots so it doesn't stunt the yield of
our crops so that we have healthy big
cabbage
so for my trial or the trial that i did
with brian um in oakfield this past
summer we went into that with the
objective to identify effective
affordable and convenient alternatives
to chlorpyrifos for control of cabbage
maggot so we were focusing on trying to
try to use lower rates of the more
expensive products directed sprays at
the base of the plant because that's the
most convenient application we also had
some transplant water applications
um but we really we didn't we're looking
at any trade wrenches because that's the
most inconvenient
um and then also i inherited a a project
from dennis willett who has left cornell
but that was to look at entomopathogenic
nematodes and i won't really talk about
too much about that in this presentation
so as i mentioned we were on farm for
this trial at root brothers this was on
ground that's
rotated with dairy farms so it's very
heavily manured it's the first field
that they plant in the season so the
trial was set up on may first and this
has this site has a history of heavy
cabbage maggot pressure
using the growers configurations we were
at the edge of the field so you can see
it was long and lean three plots wide
and probably like 500 feet long or
something like that
um
and we were using um plug
plug plants which were speedway
conqueror with the variety
so when i talk about direct the directed
spray at the base of the plant
so how we set this up on in the small
plot um i just went over with a single
single nozzle backpack sprayer i applied
40 gpa that's what i'm set up to do
unless the label specified something
different with radiant dead which is a
hundred so instead of switching the
nozzles i adjusted my walking speed but
i gotta say i was going really slow it
was kind of crazy
um that's how i that's how i adjusted
that
um and then i ended up i think my band
was more four to six as opposed to just
step four but you can see the coverage
there
um for the transm water applications on
a small scale um
so what what we did is we we used 600
gallons per acre we did a lot of math we
had to figure out how much volume of
both product and water is going down per
um row foot
and what we came up with was one fluid
ounce per plant
um
but we didn't want to put all of that
insecticide
in that foot in one plant because we
thought that would be
too concentrated so we just took that
number and divided it by four and said
okay a quarter of what goes down a foot
is going to get into that plant so
that's how we calculated that just
gently remove the already planted plants
slosh some water and put the plant in
slosh some more water in tucked it in
and gave it another and gave it another
little drink necessarily we called sarah
our bartender she was serving up drinks
and we were feeding our cabbage plants
for the pre-plant incorporated
application so the freshly planted
plants just gently removed them
backpacks sprayed across the surface
hoedom in
um just just with a garden hoe there
manually incorporated to about three to
four inches according to the label and
then replanted the plants
we also had an infra granular
application um
so we didn't bother pulling out plants
and re-digging a furrow we just
sprinkled that granular over the top and
they just kind of tucked it in a little
bit um so it wasn't exposed on the
surface but it was really in line with
the near the soil line there in the stem
where we want to have that placed anyway
so just take a look at what the maggots
were doing during the time of this trial
this is the cabbage maggot degree day
model that's available in newa um
and this is the elba weather station
because we don't have one in oakfield
and so it just shows when the
overwintering generation is present the
first the second and the and the third
generation
and so peak and peak emergence
of the overwintering generation occurred
on may 7th
so the cabbage maggot
the cabbage maggot over winter in the
soil is pupa they emerge as flies they
find a mate they lay their eggs the
larvae hatch they feed for about three
weeks then they pupate and after two to
four weeks the pupa emerges flies again
so the peak emergence of the flies of
the first generation
is due was june 14th and then the third
june 15th and the 4th august 12th
and instead of using the cabbage maggot
debris day you can use biological
indicators which are yellow rocket
daylily goldenrod and new england asters
so we planned the trial on may 1st
that's when the treatments were applied
and then we evaluated them on june 11th
so we are
definitely hitting the first generation
maybe just starting into the second
generation so when we were evaluating on
june 11th six weeks since those
applications went on
um we saw larvae from the first
generation as well as some pupa from the
first generation and we
may have started to see maggots from the
first generation but
most the vast majority of what we were
looking at was first generation
maggot feeding we took note if we saw
pupa or not um
so if we had a treatment that was very
effective we would not expect to see any
pupa
if we had a treatment that was initially
effective but um
maybe it ran out of gas and the maggots
were coming in in the last couple of
weeks if we didn't see pupa in that
situation that would be an indication
that at one time it was working very
well
um
whereas if we saw pupa that meant that
it was letting maggot through the whole
entire time if that makes sense so this
is just a visual of the adults the eggs
being laid at the soil line the maggots
feeding on the roots and then there's a
pupa
so we'll take a look at the results from
this trial we're looking at percent
cabbage maggot infestation
so
that includes whether we found maggots
in the plants or whether um we found
evidence of their feeding
and so this is the untreated we had 51
or 52
damaged plants which is a pretty good
infestation the black indicates the
number of the stunted plants that had
cabbage maggots so actually we had
stunting throughout this trial for
reasons other than cabbage maggot we
only had 33 of the stunted plants were
infested with cabbage maggot
so here's what the an example on june
10th of what the untreated checks looked
like so you can see we have some
variability we have some issues going on
in this trial with stunted with some
cultivator blight would have been one of
the issues
so i've i've starred here the two
treatments that had significantly fewer
infested plants than the untreated
they include the lures fan the directed
spray
getting us halfway there 48 control it's
it's spanned so
let's move on
the best treatment at 93 percent control
or reduction of infested plants was
diazinon egg 500 at the highest rate in
transplant water we also didn't see any
pupa it had been working great the
entire time we had no stunted plants
with cabbage maggot in them however we
did see a general 46 stunting from this
treatment 25 days after treatment
um
and it actually says on the label that
diazinone and transplant water can stump
plants so here's what the diazine looked
like on june 10th they're starting to
come out of it here's the on here's the
untreated there's the so you can kind of
see the stunting that happened there
with that treatment
the other issue with diazinon ag 500 is
that it has a lot of
ppe that's required if engineering
controls are not feasible which they are
not with your transplant
um with with the guys sitting on the
transplanter they're gonna have to wear
coveralls chemical resistant gloves not
just the nitrile gloves but the barrier
laminate which are the crunchy ones um
not very dexteritis for handling
transplants chemical resistant footwear
mixers and loaders wearing the aprons
goggles and an organo vapor um rest are
respiratory with your banana vapor
cartridges and it's restricted federally
restricted use would be requiring
on-site supervision of non-certified
handlers so your tractor driver running
that crew
would have to have a license or would
need to have on-site
supervision so it's not the most
user-friendly so what about the um the
ppi the pre-plan incorporated
well here it is high rate um you know
it's not not significantly different
than the untreated i we and we did see
some stunting 23 not as much um but it's
just it's more diluted when it's uh when
it's a broad acre spray like that and
it's it's not it's not targeting the
stem of the plants at the soil line as
well so not nearly as effective as the
transplant water application here's what
diazenon
ppi looked like
okay moving on let's take a look at
verimark we looked at this as a directed
spray at six and a half fluid ounces
which is actually it's within the label
rate but it's lower than the label rate
recommended for cabbage maggot we were
going for economics here comparing that
of course it didn't do anything
comparing that to the high rate 13 and a
half and we got almost we got a 40 we
got 43 better control or fewer infested
plants so we could see a rate
relationship there then we tried the six
and a half ounce rate in transplant
water
um
and it was somewhere in between so not
quite as good as the high rate i also
had very mark with nematodes at the low
rate of transplant water and you know
same thing as without the nematodes
nematodes weren't bringing anything to
the table
all right and here's what the vera mark
looked at we had very little stunting
with this with this treatment this is
the six and a half rate over the as the
base directed spray uh the 13 and a half
ounce rate and for some reason i had
stunting with the transplant water a
little bit
um and then here's the transplant water
treatment the nematodes where i didn't
have any starching so that was kind of
curious
okay moving on radiant here we looked at
a directed spray
at the base 100 grand or sorry 100 gpa
5 fluid ounces the lowest rate seven and
a half um 10 ounces which is the higher
rate not really seeing much of a rate
relationship going on there um and we
got we got better control with the lower
rate and then we tried a double
application of five ounces at planting
and then another five ounces 18 days
later
which was no different than the higher
rate so really not seeing too much of a
great response there and
it's kind of similar to the high rate of
very mark over the top
it also had it in the transplant water
at the low rate and that didn't really
do much for us either
and we did see pupa and we had some
stunting in this trial so this is
corragen um five ounces in transplant
water
um nothing spectacular it's labeled
suppression only
still not that still not working very
well even with the nematodes
here's that um force the infero granular
application this is not labeled but um
syngenta was curious and maybe this
could be a potential solution in the
future it's a pyrethroid
a potentially affordable option i don't
know how
user-friendly the granular and for a
granular application is but you can see
it didn't really work that great um and
then we tried following it up with the
application of radiant 18 days later
which improved a little bit but you know
none of these differences are really
significant
okay
so now let's take a look at um farooq's
data from long island we're looking at
2018 2019 and 2020 trials in blue red
and green and now we're looking at
percent roots without damage so here
it's the opposite the tall bars are the
best treatments
and you can see there's not in 2018 and
2020 there's pretty high pressure
there's not very many plants left that
don't have any damage
so which is the best treatment
it's actually insect exclusion netting
almost 100 percent control even under
high pressure he was using technet um 80
80 gram mesh so obviously not an option
for large scale but for any small
small scale growers there
in fact exclusion netting looked very
good um so that's kind of an organic
option another treatment in this trial
that would have an organic use of the
entrust which was applied as a tray
drench followed by a directed spray 14
days later and actually the trade wrench
is not labeled and trust is actually not
labeled for cabbage maggot it is labeled
brassicas
potentially there could be some
incidental control
um and it's got some activity it's
better than nothing but there's
treatments that are better
so i just wanted to mention that while
we were here
all right what is the second best
treatment after insect exclusion netting
it was laura's fan as a directed spray
we don't have that anymore so let's keep
looking
um bearer mark
also performing very well in this trial
this time it's applied as a trade drench
followed by a directed spray 14 days
later so we're double lap of the high
rate this is a lot of bear mark here
depending on the year control range from
55 to 82
the least effective with radiant
so a little bit more about the trade
wrench
applications
um
so
the way you figure out the rate is you
take the product rate per acre you
divide that by the number of plants per
acre
and that's going to give you how many
fluid ounces are going to go per plant
then you multiply that by 200 plants in
a tray and then you figure out how much
you need to put on a tray
and then you have to figure out how much
water that goes in
and that's going to be experiment
experiment experimenting just to figure
out how much water you need to saturate
the plugs
and not but not to the point of runoff
because you don't want your insecticide
to run out of the bottom
so what worked out for farooq
was um 4.7 mils
or 0.16 fluid ounces in a tr in a in one
pint of water per tray he sprayed that
over the top and then came back with
another pint of water per tray
over top
to walk over top of the foliage to wash
it in
and the label states that the treated
plants need to go
need to be planted within 72 hours of
this application they also recommend not
watering for 24 hours before you make
the applications
and so then you can get make sure that
the insecticide gets in the ball where
they need to be
so to compare a directed spray to a
trade drench i pulled some data from
california we're looking at percent
plants with maggot injury
so high bars are bad the untreated had
35 percent of the plants were injured
and for very mark high rate radiant high
rate we're comparing a trade wrench
versus a directed spray and you can see
in the side by side comparisons that the
trade wrench has two to three times more
injured plants than the ch
than the trade wrench does i don't know
i said that right the directed spray has
more
um infestation than the trade wrench so
this is a con this is a consistent trend
that we're seeing throughout all the
research trials that we've been looking
at whatever what's in that was published
in the literature um the trade range
seems to be the most effective
way to or the the most effective
application technique
for using these types of products
and it makes sense when we were doing
our trial evaluating the plugs we saw
all kinds of maggots stuck in that root
ball so if that root ball is full of
insecticide you just have to believe
that's gonna go a long way towards
controlling the maggots
so everything i've talked about so far
has been total infestation but obviously
there's a difference between a plant
that's severely infested that has no
root left
and that can cause stunting versus one
that's just got a few feeding canals and
it's probably not going to affect yield
loss at all
so in our in our trial last year we did
not look at that so all of my treatments
that are not significantly different if
we were to look at severity i bet you we
would start seeing
they would start separating out and
that's what we plan to do moving forward
but farooq has been doing this the whole
time and he's been using a scale of one
to ten in increasing severity with um
i think he said anything in the the
three to one category is not going to
affect yields um certainly something
that's eight to ten is going to cause
serious economic losses
so here's his data with respect to root
damage severity
um this is the 2018 to 20
20
2018 to 2020 trials again so you can see
in those two years we had hot 2018 2020
very high pressure approaching 3.5 of
course that's an average there's going
to be some of those plants as we know
um
that are going to have
high levels of infestation but that's a
pretty high average and you can see all
of the treatments in that trial had very
minor very minor injury
at averaging out at once
um
so
in truth you know i think we know that
brassicas can tolerate a certain extent
of feeding without causing with it
without it causing marketable damage
and another thing to point out this is
with respect to bearer mark in farouk's
2020 trial he's looking at percent leaf
damage caused by flea beetle and
caterpillars the untreated in the column
on the right
and a black plastic mulch which is
essentially an untreated um and you can
see that they've got very high levels of
damage or 10 whatever um and then the
vera mark though like absolutely no
feeding damage at all no caterpillar
feeding so vera mark also is offering
protection against flea beetles and
um caterpillars and that's the trade
judge followed by a directed spray 14
days later you see radiant laura's band
have a little bit of activity on flea
beetle but they didn't do very well in
this trial
for the caterpillars
and then this chart here is a
head quality rating at harvest and so
the untreated is not is very poor
um
the insect closing netting is pretty
good but even better than the exclusion
netting was very mark so really nice
looking heads at the end of harvest
because it's controlling other pests
other than just cabot cabbage maggot and
there wasn't any further insecticides
applied to control these other pests so
that's really showy in this data
all right i want to um finish with one
last data set saving the best for last
this is farook 2021 we're looking at
roots without damage so tall bars are
good
and in this trial the untreated had 42
only 42 less than half of the plants
um were healthy you can see five stars
up here that were significantly better
than the untreated with giving 85 to 97
clean plants representing 74 to 95
percent control so what are they
well four of those treatments are a new
experimental pipeline product
um won't be available for 2022 but
hopefully this is sometime that's
something that you will see in your
future
here's vera mark just as a point of
reference uh 52 56 control and this is
just with the trade wrench not with that
follow-up
um directed spray 14 days later so
what's this mystery remaining star what
is it what is it
it is mustang max a directed spray a
pyrethroid over the top or
directed spray at the base of the plant
at planting and then every week for
three for three weeks after for a total
of four sprays giving eighty percent
control
so the thing about mustang max
it's labeled on brassicas for flea
beaters and calipers
caterpillars and onions it's not
specifically labeled on um
cabbage maggot
there could be some incidental control
of cabbage maggot but i would spec i
would suspect that would only concur
occur if you're actually spraying it at
the base of the plants
um but i think this is something that
our team is going to look at to see if
we can get a 2ee label because that
would be relatively
simple
um and probably affordable as well
all right so to summarize the alter
alternatives that we have for laura's
van well the diazinon is one of them the
transplant water application is by far
more effective than the pre-plan
incorporated
um not that the ppi wouldn't have any
utility under lower pressure i would
presume but under high pressure you
would um i think it would fall apart for
you this has the longest residual
control but there's a lot of things
against it there's the risk of stunting
so you want to apply an insecticide so
cabbage maggot doesn't stunt your
cabbage but the product you're using can
stunt the cabbage so kind of
i don't know may or may not negate
itself there it's federally in new york
state restricted it's got extensive pe
ppe for the transplant water application
um and it doesn't offer any control of
flea beetles or cabbage farms
so the other alternative is um veramark
tree drench
the high rate is is averaging about 65
to 80 percent control which increases by
10 to 15
when you follow that up with a directed
spray at the base two to three weeks
later our trials have been with veramark
but theoretically it could be something
else
um it also offers excellent control of
flea beaters and caterpillars
um the rate
it varies by your plant population so
the highest
density plantings are going to get the
lowest rate per plant
so that's something i think we need to
look into
a little bit further as we move forward
with our trials is what is the rapid
plant that really works
and work back that way
um it's very user friendly i don't even
think the ppe requires gloves it's just
long sleeves
long sleeve pants long sleeve shirt and
pants
long sleeve sleeves and pants um
and shoes and socks it is expensive it's
probably around 100 for that high rate
but you have to factor in what is the
value of of the flea beetle and the worm
control that you're going to get in that
package
and the transplant trade wrench is
certainly
inconvenient i know growers are pretty
good at figuring things out and i think
once a system is figured out it'll it'll
probably work but it's going to be a
learning curve and it doesn't have it
doesn't offer the residual that the
diastone does it'll it'll probably start
running out of gas around that four week
mark i think
um
so far from our work the the trans the
transplant water and the directed sprays
at the base are much less effective than
the transplant or than the
trade wrench
so not strongly recommending those right
now especially with the cost of this
product
you'll get some activity with radiant um
it's not a it hasn't been a shiny star
but it is labeled
um and then just a reminder for organic
organic use there is an insect exclusion
netting which is phenomenal and it also
controls flea beetles and caterpillars
also sweet midge i'll talk about that a
bit later
um
the caveat is you have to put it on
ground that's rotated out of brassicas
you don't want insect pests to emerge
into the netting and you don't want to
be transplanting plants into it that are
already infested with um worms for
example it's expensive it's labor
intensive it's not ideal for large scale
but it's not it's not it's not um just
for organic a conventional grower could
potentially get a lot of use out of
insect exclusion netting
so there's a lot more to come that's
where we're at this is the corner
cabbage magnet team as i mentioned dan
gilgrain gets the award for cabbage
maggot longevity uh we are uh for rook
zaman myself and brian nalt
and
um both of both of them are on the
zoom today so if there's any questions
i guess i'm going to stop sharing my
screen right now
gemma do you want to launch our poll
so the question is just a little
activity for you how are you feeling
about cabbage maggot control without
lore's ban
okay
so
56
good seven percent excess million
nineteen percent not good
emma were there any questions in the
chat or does anybody want christy may i
say something real quick
first of all excellent job
you really covered this topic really
really well so i want to mention that
first
the other is maybe just to elaborate on
just a couple of the comments that you
made um and the first is that even
though there are multiple cabbage maggot
generations over the course of the
summer it seems that the biggest
problems occur with that first
generation and that perhaps us a
veramark drench or any other type of
control may not be
necessary for pla plantings later in the
summer
so that's one point and the other is in
terms of the veramark potentially
running out of gas after four or five
weeks again is if that plant can get
established pretty well
i feel like you know even if there are
some maggots that infest the plant it's
probably not going to hurt the plant
because the root system is going to be
pretty well developed
so i think it's just critical for those
earliest plantings and to really get
that protection for you know a good four
to five weeks and should be good so
anyway that's that's all i wanted to
elaborate
but thank you for an excellent
presentation
and thank you for taking on cabbage
maggot brian
all right well i
didn't plan to go over to roll right
into the next presentation but
um
tom i guess thomas is delayed and will
be joining us later so we're just gonna
keep working with the maggot maggot
megan because the larvae of sweden is
also a maggot and um you're gonna hear
from me again
um i'm gonna talk about new developments
for managing sweden in brassica crops in
from 2015 to 2017 i worked with seven
small-scale
organic brassica farms in new york state
from ithaca to olean in the southern
tier and we were monitoring sweden's
populations intensively and relating
that to management practices and damage
that we were seeing on the crop as well
as
um conducting several on-farm trials and
demonstrations and so we learned a
tremendous amount about sweden on
through that project
for which i wanted to share with you
some of the highlights today
so hopefully everybody knows what sweet
midge is it's a tiny little fly
it's only two millimeters in size
truthfully you're probably not going to
see them in your
brassica crops unless you're monitoring
for them and you see a dead body on a
sticky card
those tiny little flies lay tiny little
legs they target the growing points of
plants they really like that newly
developing tissue those tiny eggs hatch
into larvae
and the larvae i gotta say these can be
tricky to find too if you don't know
what you're
looking for and so i just want to let
you know that a few years ago i made a
diagnostic video it's only one minute if
you do a search better know a past sweet
midge it should pop up and it'll just
walk you through the steps you need to
take to find those actual larvae
because the damage that sweet midge
causes can be confused with
other ailments of brassicas because they
tend to morph morph so to really confirm
you have sweet image ideally you like to
find the culprit so this is just an
example of puckering leaf puckering
damage that swedens can cause um when
they're feeding on the growing point and
that gets disrupted you can have
multiple side shoots or heads as in the
case of cabbage and as you know several
things can cause this to occur in
cabbage heads and certainly not always
sweet meds what's really diagnostic for
me is the brown quirky scarring which
when it's in the head of cauliflower
broccoli deens the
marketable portion of the plant
unmarketable
um so a little can cause a lot of damage
what's important to know about the life
cycle just like the cabbage flies that
overwinters in the soil is pupa emerges
as adults as adults have three days to
meet they lay a whole bunch of eggs that
hatch within three days the larvae feed
for two to three weeks they drop to the
soil to pupate and then emerge after one
to two weeks and the cycle starts again
we have about four or five overlapping
generations in new york this is trap
catch data from one of the farms that i
work with um
first trap catches were around may 15th
um we certainly never caught anything in
april never caught anything the first
week of may and our last trap catches
honestly could be in november
um so the blue
lines here these are the spring
emergence sites so this is where you had
an infested brassica the previous fall
so this is where they're emerging in the
spring and then you can see they're
moving into the summer planting and
they're moving into the or the spring
and from the spring to the summer and
then into the fall and you can see all
along the way when it's not well
controlled they can build tremendously
within a season and you can see
um multiple overlapping
generations and now that our falls are
getting warmer um we're start this this
patch
is going fairly strongly throughout the
month of october
so conventionally
it's very it's relatively easy to
control sweden with insecticides these
this is the roster of what we have
labeled in new york neonics um
warrior movento and xrel belonging to
four different classes the um the
neonics movento and x-rail are probably
going to get you very good to excellent
control so even if you're using these
products for thrips or aphids or
worms
you're going to get you're probably
going to be getting control of again
incidental control of swede midge um and
i just also wanted to mention that
corrigen besiege and mayor mer vera mark
i mentioned that earlier um these are
other group 28 insecticides
labeled in brassicas not specifically
for sweden but again when you're using
them to control your worms or your
maggots or whatever else that you're
probably controlling sweet midge at the
same time so just want to point that out
my experience working with conventional
growers um i see cabbage maggot every
now and again i personally have never
seen it cause economic damage and
usually a grower might just tweak his
spray program just a little bit to maybe
use one of these products that'll um get
that sweet population under control or
preventing it from even getting out of
control probably more realistic
the other most effective way to manage
sweden is with far and wide crop
rotation
um and with like large-scale cabbage
production where fields only going into
cabbage maybe every four years and it's
being rotated with field crops
predominantly vine crops um
sweet midge doesn't really stand a
chance
but organic growers are more vulnerable
because they tend to be small scale and
so the small land base with a high
proportion of that acreage crop to
brassica crops and multiple planting
season long
really negates the ability to rotate
effectively and also organic
insecticides are nowhere near as good as
conventional insecticides
but through all that work that i did
with the small-scale growers and
monitoring their populations
we were able to come up with new crop
rotation recommendations that are much
more easier for them to implement than
the original recommendations which were
three thousand feet
between cross between brassica crops
just thinking
just the further the better and then
three years and the thought behind the
three-year product was because a portion
of those pupa will overwinter in the
soil for more than a year
um
so what i was able to do is get that
down to about 500 feet
however there's a caveat here the fields
must be separated they must be secluded
fields separated by a substantial
barrier such such as a wooded area to
really get those so those flies get lost
and going from one field to another we
had i was working on farms that had
either an 8 acre or 12 acre field with
maybe 500 feet between one side of the
field and the other the sweden
eventually did find their way to the to
the brassicas so without a barrier
500 feet is not enough so i want to make
that clear
and basically we get that three years
down to two and a half to three months
which is basically you can you can go
back into the same field um you just
have to wait until that spring emergence
has subsided
so um these new recommendations are
which i'll explain a little well i'll
explain more in a moment but i just
wanted to let you know that um there's a
new fact sheet out that outlines all of
them so if you just do a search for crop
rotation sweet image you should find our
fact sheet ready enough
so um
to illustrate the waiting for spring
emergence to subside these are the trap
the dash line is the trap catches of the
spring emergence so this is where this
is the site where you had infested
brassicas the previous fall
and then the solid line is the sweet
image in the um
this is red cabbage and so in this case
they planted the cabbage on april 25th
so overlapping was spring emergence and
the swedes had no trouble finding the
red cabbage and by the end of the season
only 28
of those heads were marketable
this is when you're catching
almost 100 swedens per trap per day so
this is really heavy infestation here's
another field where
they planted the red cabbage on july
22nd so you can see the spring emergence
has really subsided here it's not gone
completely but it's certainly not at
this level and yeah it found it found
the red cabbage but they ended up with
98 marketable heads
so
um this proved to be a very effective
way of um
being able to go back into the same
field you just have to delay the
planting two or three months until the
spring emergence has subsided
so um as i mentioned it only works with
secluded fields that are separated by a
significant barrier
um
you have to make sure that the
transplants are not infested with sweet
mitch that was an issue and some of some
of the farms i work with that they
they held off on brassica production and
they went in in the fall but then their
processes were full of the transplants
were full of sweden so it completely
defeated the purpose and it's very
helpful to combine crop rotation um with
post-harvest crop destruct
um to prevent sweet image populations
from building i'll illustrate that in a
moment and also avoiding cover crops
such as mustard mustard types cover
crops when you're rotating away from
brassicas they don't tend to be the most
preferred host but if that's all they're
given you know if you have another
option i would i would recommend it
so this is just an example of how swede
midge can build after harvest
so this is the main harvest of broccoli
where there's no practically no sweet
midge at all and just as just as they
let it go to harvest the second
secondary side shoots it starts to build
then their flail mower is broken and
next thing you know um the crop isn't by
the time the crop is mowed that
population has increased 13-fold to
very very high levels i would have
rather just got some of that secondary
side shoot harvest flail mold it and cut
all this out
so this is the crop rotation
outline that's in the fact sheet so
basically it starts with a farm that has
two fields that are heavily infested and
so the growers going to have to take one
of those fields out of production and in
the other wait until the spring
emergence has subsided before he goes in
or she goes in with fall brassicas then
in the second year you basically pick
the field that you think has the lowest
pressure which in this case would be the
field that we took out of rotation
completely we're going to run spring and
summer brassicas in that field we're not
going to take them through the entire
season because we don't want the um the
sweden to build up
that far
um and then switch to the other field
after spring emergence has decided to
come in with the fall brassicas and then
it's just a constant flip-flopping back
and forth with splint planting your
spring brass because spring and summer
brassicas in the one field and then
moving and then finishing up the fall
once after
spring emergence has subsided in the
other
um
it monitoring sweden so you kind of have
an idea what this invisible pest is
doing on your farm can be done with
pheromone traps and if you're interested
in that if you go to the sweden
information center in the u.s
um just click on monitoring detection
and it goes through where to get the pla
where to get the traps how to identify a
speed image on a sticky card it's really
quite it's really quite useful
um
and the other thing that came out of
that work was what is the relative
preference of sweden um of the different
brassica crops and so we actually came
up we will line them up in a scale here
this is in that fact sheet as well with
the most preferred being red russian
kale followed by broccoli broccoli of
course if you have a little bit of
scarring in a head
versus a kale where you have several
leaves to choose from
we send we tend to see the highest
economical losses with broccoli
and then on the other end the more
tolerant crops are the asian brassicas
chinese and savoy cabbage and bok choy
winterboro kale turnips and radishes um
so if you're in a situation where you
have you know you've got sweden you want
to plant some brassicas you know maybe
you can plant some of these more
tolerant ones and we have seen
we have
we
it's amazing
how what high pressure of sweet image i
have seen chinese cabbage with stand or
bok choy for that matter without without
they they don't go to it even in a cage
i had them in a cage they had no choice
they still didn't want to infest it it
was fascinating to me
um
so but if you're in a situation where
you have a susceptible brassica and
you've got a high sweepage population
there is the option of insect exclusion
netting we have demonstrated it several
times to provide 100 of control of
sweden just like it does a phenomenal
job controlling cabbage maggot what
we're talking about is pro technet 25
grams
um it costs about 200 dollars for a
hundred feet of protection and that's
with the four inch or sorry the four
foot hoops and then you have about
another two hundred dollars in the
supplies the hoops the clamps the
anchors and whatnot it needs to be
secured
um which is labor intensive sometimes we
rock it in sometimes we sold it in and
it's best when it's accompanied with a
mulch this is landscape fabric whether
it's a
plastic mold straw mulch but that helps
keeps the weeds out so you don't have to
go in there to weed and here's a and if
if you don't secure the sides they can
blow in the wind weeds can lift them up
animals can get in there
once sweet mix gets in there they do
very well inside this environment
another advantage to the insect
exclusion netting is we have advanced
maturity you can see that these were
planted at the exact same time the
difference between outside and in the
hoop or inside the netting some of that
is because they provide phenomenal
control of flea beetles as i already
mentioned
um
caterpillars as well um oops
on the other side as i mentioned before
if you put transplants underneath
netting that's already infested
they are going to go crazy in there it's
going to look like a snow globe of
cabbage butterflies i've seen it it's a
thing
um
also if you're not weeding like in the
hoops
um
it can be a good it can be a good
environment for slugs so you know fix
one pest and create another so that's
something to be aware of you might want
to weed or use some slug bait or
something
um the economics of the
the economics of the insect exclusion
netting um because it's very expensive
it's only economically feasible under
high pressure situations so if you're
standing to lose 50 of your crop or more
and you've got a high value crop so
something like three dollar per pound
broccoli otherwise you may as well just
grow broccoli in the open air and feed
half of it to the speed which you get to
the same place
um however if you see the advantages of
the the flea beetle and the worm control
um that could play into that decision
um
the advanced maturity and also what's
the value of keeping a potentially
lucrative market
um i don't know if i'm i think i
mentioned this i'm not sure if i did but
again this has to be rotated to ground
that hasn't been corrupted brassicas in
about three years so we had a study with
a permanent bed system
we literally moved three beds over
um from a severely infested spot to one
that hadn't been cropped to brassicas
and grew like had perfect control of
speedbunch
um the netting can be reused to
an extent if you're if you're rocking it
in it comes out a little bit better than
if you're sodding it in if you're
sodding it in it tends to um
tear when you remove it so this grower
used this netting on the forefoot
tunnels and broccoli and then turned it
around and put it over top of kohlrabi
so he could reuse it that way
and lastly the last thing i'm working on
um for the farms where they can't rotate
insect exclusion netting is just not
working um is the idea of using ground
barriers that you would put over top of
an infested site and so the sweden would
theoretically emerge under there and
perish then you can pull off the tarp
and you've crashed your sweden's
population so
while your infested ground is containing
the swede mid theoretically you could
grow your broccoli right beside it so um
i've looked at landscape fabric
tarp and um plastic mulch and i tried
the plastic mulch with in the landscape
fabric with and without holds because i
was wondering if you could um just put
onions in or something like that turns
out swedenbish have no trouble finding
the holes so you're going to have to
take the ground out of production we're
down to tarping and landscape fabric
both of these
will result in different moisture and
temperature conditions under the tarp
which could affect what happens to the
swede midge
um but so far my preliminary small cage
trials that were done with artificial
speed mid inoculation um when we pulled
the barriers off after 30 and 46 days
there was no more emergence so we
assumed that they perished but the next
step is to try this with a naturally
infested soil where you've got over
overlapping generations emerging at
different times and we really want to
know how long do those tarps have to be
or does that ground barrier have to be
there
and that is it
and i i'm at 12 51 we're expecting
thomas at 12 55
so oh funding for this project
northeastern partnership program
northeast ipm and the cornell's tour
sustainability foundation
so i'm going to stop sharing so i can
see
um
christine
we have one question in the chat um
lauren would like to know does anybody
have experience using netting without
tubes
oh yes you can
yeah you can use it um just placing it
over top a low
um like a lower to the lower to the
ground crop
um again secure
just securing it so it doesn't blow away
and
so that um sweet image doesn't get get
under it but but that can work too
all right so is thomas here
i am indeed
oh thomas
i was going to make a maggot sandwich
out of you i was going to talk about a
maggot and then have you talk about
broccoli and then me maggot i know
it was it's maggot maggot broccoli
okay um so thomas is going to
talk about potential solutions to the
five most common reasons why growers
don't go broccoli so i have an f word
for broccoli and that is fickle
so thomas is a plant physiologist with
the department of horticulture at
cornell agritech and i think
he's
i don't know was it 12 years ago that
you okay so 12 years ago he decided that
he wanted to
lead the eastern broccoli project which
has the ambitious goal of developing uh
a broccoli industry in the east eastern
united states
so
the never lacking ambition with never
lacking admission thomas bjorkman
tell us how to solve
pickle broccoli problem
yeah
so
thanks a lot and uh yeah thanks for
accommodating the time switch i i just
got back to talking to the ontario
growers
just pulled in um
uh
so yeah thanks for accommodating the the
time shift so fickle broccoli it is it
is challenging there's no question
there's a lot of opportunity there are
people who are making it work and it's
working well for them
um
when we first started this project it
was cornell or sorry new york state is a
great place to grow cabbage people
really know how to produce coal crops
and the land is really well suited for
it the climate except for a couple of
small issues is well suited to it we
should do great with this and uh one of
the
first things we realized is that if
you're making money growing cabbage you
don't want to give up any cabbage ground
for broccoli and the management is
completely different once you've
harvested it so it turns out the cabbage
growers
were actually some of the least likely
growers so it's a little bit challenging
to talk at this session about
why did it
grow broccoli i realize that's a
challenge
but i see on the participant list that
some of you have
done it and have
quite a few
answers to this question also
but looking
back over a lot of the things i'm i'm
gonna uh just summarize some of the some
of the things we have so these are not
easy problems to solve but
that has not changed uh but there are
some things to look at
but first of all start optimistically
why should you raise
broccoli so it is still true as it was
uh 12 years ago that locally grown
produce is in demand there are quite a
few buyers who are interested in getting
it the landscape for that has changed a
little bit
um as markets always do
we have reduced transportation costs
versus california so i just uh checked
this week a reefer from salinas to new
york costs eleven thousand dollars so
that's eleven dollars the box and so if
you're getting twenty dollars a box
then uh you've got
about a 55 percent advantage uh if well
if your transportation costs were
nothing but they're not um it's a big
advantage right so
you can take advantage of that to
be able to deliver even if your
production costs are higher than
california
the market is still interested in a
reduced footprint or sustainably
produced these are all important things
to many buyers
and
new york growers can deliver on that
for
many growers crop diversification is
valuable
that's why broccoli is grown in
california at all is for diversification
of the
lettuce production areas that's the
whole big driver behind it
and so for
having a more greater diversity of
markets
greater diversity of timing in the crops
that you're growing
so with
cabbage growers obviously that's not
that's one of the
the problems that i'm going to be
talking about
and
looking nationally having a
diversification of the supply sources
for
broccoli or any crop
is important if all of it is in
one valley then the country's at risk
for a shortage there's no doubt about it
that's not a compelling reason for an
individual grower but it is a compelling
reason for congress
the california expansion of broccoli to
meet the continually growing demand for
broccoli is limited by the amount of
land and water that they have and more
and more of the water
and in fact
for the last five or six years
the increased demand in the united
states has mostly been met from
guanajuato in mexico their production
has increased quite a lot so they're
now up to about 25 percent of our
u.s consumption
from
it was
maybe four or five percent before it's
increased a lot and it's basically the
entire increase in the demand has come
uh
has been met by mexican production a
tiny bit by uh
eastern production but some of some of
the uh eastern demand
has been met by eastern production so
it's it is happening
um i would say that the so before the it
was like almost all the production was
in maine there's a
little bit of winter production in
florida florida production has expanded
and has expanded into
uh south georgia and a little bit south
carolina for supplying the winter market
maine is staying steady the largest
increases have really been in the
mid-atlantic so the higher elevations in
uh virginia and north carolina is where
we've seen a lot and that is partly
because there has been strong
distribution
out of that area for new broccoli
growers that we haven't had to the same
extent uh in new york
so that's why
doing it why don't people do it there's
a lot of reason so the top five uh
varieties they're not adapted to the
east that's what we've been mostly
working on that the markets despite the
high demand
the markets that you have are not making
it worthwhile
um then the biggie especially for this
audience you've already raising cabbage
or you're already using cruise for cover
crops for important roles you don't have
space for more coal crops
then
number four is that it takes too much
labor so when we look at
grower surveys of what their biggest
issues are it's almost always labor and
in the last few weeks that has certainly
been the top of agenda for new york
vegetable growers
and
of course that is an issue in broccoli
too because it is a hand harvested crop
and then finally lack of cooling we
found this to be a tremendously
important limitation
to producers
so what do you do about unadapted
varieties so this is where we've been
growing varieties that are more adapted
to the eastern climate and one of the
nice things about raising in salinas is
that you have extremely fertile soil
you've got really quite predictable
rainfall you've got irrigation
you've got cool nights
it's really an ideal climate for growing
in the east
we get quite a bit of water
we just don't necessarily get it when we
want it it can be too much too little
high humidity the high night time
temperatures that cause deformation of
the heads is a real problem
and
just the variability from year to year
from week to week
from county to county is enormous here
so we need a high level of environmental
resilience in each and every variety
that we plant
and the old varieties just did not cut
it
um
so one thing is not to raise the old
stuff that's a pretty easy one so
pacman's was an old reliable one it's
consistently mediocre
which was the best we could do it in the
past
but
mediocre doesn't cut it in today's
markets okay pac-man doesn't work
green magic was very popular when we
started this project
because it was the best
modern variety for the east but it's not
a very good one new ones are a lot
better
marathon
classic fall variety had a huge market
you see it in just about every catalog
completely inappropriate for the east
if you really want to go back
the chico an open pollinated one is
essentially unimproved
from when broccoli was imported to the
united states from southern italy 100
years ago it makes a nice small bunch in
broccoli it's still very popular um with
market gardeners
it has a great story behind it but it is
not a commercial broccoli variety by any
stretch
and then any variety that's been bred
specifically for salinas because salinas
is a giant market all the companies have
their breeding facilities near salinas
they are breeding for salinas that's not
our climate so things that do well there
are not necessarily going to do well
here so we need stuff that works well in
the east so we've tested a bunch of
material and have worked with seed
companies to develop new material so the
current leader in the east is without a
doubt eastern crown it's probably over
50
of the market
uh because it makes a very heavy head
it's a it's a big yielder and it is
pretty resilient
we have planting trials where we've
managed to get it to break down too so
it's not bulletproof
and
more adapted things are coming along
there's a new variety out called abrams
that does quite well
imperial has been the worldwide
hot season
varieties of in
areas where they're growing in a warm
season growing going into a hot season
desert that sort of thing
they often finish with imperial
and so it plays a role there
we can make that one come apart here
also
lieutenant is one that was uh
it was released by feminists a long time
ago they had it they had the seeds they
just stopped selling it because it
didn't really compete in salinas but it
turns out it does quite well in the east
so they got it back on the market so
it's basically back on the market just
for us
and so that that's been uh
playing a
meaningful part in the eastern
production bernie came out uh from bao
early in the
in the project it was one of their first
crosses that was tested specifically
under eastern conditions and stood out
as doing well so that's been on the
market for a while
and that that does well uh bay meadows
is a variety from
uh syngenta
that was similar story to lieutenant
um
that it
does well it's very early but it it
holds up well
and it's basically only on the market
for the east so it may not
justify
uh marketing by
by syngenta for very much longer but for
the time being that's good and then we
have new stuff coming that's the
exciting part
num things with numbers uh things that
seed is being increased and they're
planning the marketing campaign
and
uh actually some of those
with the seed they have they're trialing
those it's some of the larger growers so
they're they're kicking around so if
you're you're a big grower you may have
heard of
uh
some of those numbered materials so
there are varieties to use some big
emphasis on get good material
for the market marketing vegetables is a
killer business boy that is one lesson
that i have learned
from
being part of this project
so
i don't know that i can give experienced
growers any
great insight on this one but perhaps
the rest of you who haven't
been
uh immersed into this
uh
some of the challenges so
uh
we thought
naively in the beginning that was so
much broccoli on the market so much
demand for broccoli every supermarket
every institution has to have broccoli
and so
there should just be this big
marketplace for broccoli and you just
get a broker and put it on the market
and you get whatever the market price is
and that works out okay no nothing like
that
um so just calling a broker when you
harvest you're probably going to get
a lowball price so that's not going to
work
trying to compete directly with the
commodity channel um
is
really hard because you're going to be
the lowest priority going to get the
lowest price and
um
just those established relationships are
are not there that's not going to work
and again this is another relationship
thing
walmart is actually considered by the
people who deliver to walmart to be
quite a good reliable buyer of broccoli
if you follow their rules
they always accept the product and they
always pay you for it
on a timely basis wonderful from a you
know it's not the highest price but it
you know what the price is going to be
so you can
make sure that you're producing so
people like
delivering to walmart despite their
reputation for really driving prices way
down for suppliers
but you can't get a walmart contract if
you
don't already have a relationship with
them they
like people they've been working with
for a couple of decades
so that
so calling them up and trying to get on
their list is is pretty unlikely
so do try building on existing
relationships this seems to be
what has been successful
and
so there are many buyer relationships
in fact just to jump back on walmart
i've seen some places where
they've wanted
more supply from a particular grower
they can't deliver but
they can
be the agent for neighboring growers to
deliver on their walmart
contract so then it's the relationship
between the neighbors
you know can that neighbor deliver
to walmart's specifications
um at the production cost so it builds
on that relationship so the trusted
relationship between
the
wholesale buyer and the grower and then
the grower relationships
some of those work well some of them
weren't terrible
you know your relationships
another is to identify the exact
consumer specifications
every customer has different
specifications that they want the kind
of box the length of stem the diameter
of the head
how much stuff is how many how much
broccoli is in a box the amount of ice
has to be ice no ice
very different specifications you have
to know exactly what they are
and that you can deliver them
that is super important
and then we're seeing local institutions
particularly in new york state there's
incentive for schools and institutions
to buy local
and they are interested and they don't
know how to do it
so
talking to local school districts to see
what they want
broccoli is a nice back to school in the
fall
having it on their menu
but what exactly do they need
what kind of price can they
pay what's the volume that they're
interested in
you have to figure that out usually well
in advance
but that's where we're seeing some real
possibilities
school districts and
also
senior housing
they go through a lot of food
and they like to serve people vegetables
and broccoli is really easy for them to
use
so that's a local institution that's
they can have significant volume
uh
all right
other coal crops
since we have brassica growers here
already uh
if you're doing well with what you have
already then probably it's not broccoli
that's that's going to be
one of the simple answers
but if you do want to try broccoli so
one thing don't try to shorten your
crucifer rotation that will only lead to
disaster so that's
i think uh
christy talked quite a bit about that in
the preceding talks on just the insect
front on why you don't want to do that
and the other thing is not to try
raising broccoli as if it were cabbage
so they both like
high fertility ground
so in terms of
getting the broccoli planted
and the first few weeks that is very
similar to cabbage
you do have to plant broccoli at roughly
three times the plant population of
cabbage to make money
but that's not a hugely difficult uh
transition
but other other than that um
what are things to try so
first of all doing small acreage uh
where you have
a market that you think you can get a
high enough profit margin to justify it
that's
definitely worth trying it uh it's it's
too expensive a crop to grow to have a
bunch of speculative acreage
that doesn't work
but then exploring the in-season market
channels that may complement
your marketing season
particularly with storage crops
so that would be late august september
october
and then if you can pull it off
if you're close to the lake you might be
able to
demand really goes up for thanksgiving
and some years
you can it's it's cool enough that the
broccoli holds reasonably well in the
field
and
if you're using
brassica cover crops
for soil health benefits think of
broccoli as your cover crop so
it's almost playing that role
for the lettuce growers in salinas
but they're they're using it for disease
control it's actually pretty good as a
cover crop it's way too expensive to use
as a cover crop that's why it's not used
and
so incorporating it
quickly and you just heard why
incorporating quickly is valuable for
the sweet midge
management you don't want old broccoli
sitting around in the field that's not
going to help anything
but
the residue and the broccoli roots
can be quite valuable for disease
control and for recovering nitrogen
so those are so they're not not a lot of
answers on this one to be honest it's
just
if your other
cold crops or brassica cover crops are
playing an important role it is very
difficult to justify getting into
broccoli but if it would be if if on the
market front or on the rotation front
you have
a good reason to do it
labor's a tough one of course and
nobody's coming up with easy solutions
on that one
so you're probably not going to find
extra labor for the broccoli harvest
but another aspect if you do have labor
is don't try using untrained labor
because the specifications are so
particular you need a broccoli
a trained broccoli crew to do it and you
can you can definitely train one
we had one of the
medium-sized uh
broccoli companies in california
i was talking to them about labor you
know what about
sending one of their harvest crews to
new york for the harvest season um to
supply their markets in the east and
then they'd save themselves the shipping
and they'd have control over the quality
because they had their own crew
and you know they were thinking about it
you know they really didn't have a spare
crew and that
they might have a spare cauliflower crew
but that was kind of unimaginable
because the cauliflower harvesters
really didn't know how to cut broccoli
right so that gives you an idea of the
level of precision that they were
looking for in their broccoli crew
so
the one
solution that i've seen work the best is
timing the broccoli harvest
on your farm when it complements your
harvest availability so there are
peak and slack seasons for every crop
and so putting broccoli in where it's a
slack season for your other crops that
um not huge insights
in coming up with that one but that uh
because the broccoli is really pretty
predictable when the harvest is going to
come up uh you can time that reasonably
well
but with the cruise you have to practice
for the speed and the cut and the
presentation in the box because that's
what the buyers are looking for
i've timed the broccoli cruise
and they run about three seconds per
head average going down the field so
that's pretty good clip
and if the
um
i know one farm was paying peace rate
they were paying a dollar a box
um
so
if you're gonna have somebody making
enough money at a dollar a box they are
moving fast
so
getting the technique down
for how to move at that speed while
keeping the quality just tip top
now one
buyer may want a stem that's three
fingers and the other one wants just two
fingers uh
you need to get that knife to hit the
stem at just the right spot every single
time every three seconds
uh it's not easy to do it takes a
special crew to do that so you do have
to practice that to get it where it's up
to snuff
and the final one is lack of cooling and
this is what the big distributors tell
us we'd like to source more from new
york but there just isn't the cooling
capacity we need to be shipping cold
broccoli that has ice on it
and so letting the broccoli stay warm is
just not a player it goes bad way too
quickly you have to cool broccoli you
have to have the capacity
and
if you
don't have the capacity at all
there are some local markets where
they're going to use the broccoli
immediately
they're not very big but that would be
the ones to get into and the other is
investing in cooling and investing in
cooling is expensive there is no
question about that
um
at the low end i'd say a hundred
thousand dollars is probably the minimum
capital investment if you're going to
get into it and a million or two
for a big grower is definitely in the
ballpark of what it would cost to have
enough refrigeration capacity
ice storage um
the actual cooling equipment itself
there is some
vacuum coolers for rent that you could
lease for the growing season
but here i'm showing you a proof of our
a new bulletin coming out an extension
publication on cooling methods this is
just the proof from
the latest version but it should be out
in a few weeks and it would be a
comprehensive
guide for eastern growers as to what
would be the best
the best option on your farm
so those are the top five reasons i
think people are not raising broccoli
and in many cases that is the right
decision
but
in some cases there is a solution
that could get you into broccoli so
those are some of my ideas on that so
with that
i'll take that one down
all right thank you thomas
so you just you just did a presentation
in canada turn around to the
presentation and
i did one in sweden on tuesday oh my
goodness
canada yesterday
new york here so yeah
all over
all right um well thank you um
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu